[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream our 637th is that correct
and a half and a half yes yeah i forgot
the half
sorry my bad uh actually what number is
it
it's 57 57. all right that's a lot of
live streaming
um it is yeah so we have um
four topics we have four topics um and
uh although neither of us really love to
do this uh we should start
the top of the hour by saying what we
did last week at the point that it was
only 24 hours old that
um there are now there's now merch
available
including the title of last week's
episode your algorithm is no good here
on t-shirts hopefully on hats at some
point although that takes some
embroidery
yes yeah so hopefully in a socially
distanced park near you
sooner rather than later i'm not sure
you can buy it at a socially distance no
no i'm hoping people will wear them at
the park
yeah so that you can go to
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
to to find those things uh if you want
to while you're
awesome and as long as we have sullied
ourselves by
you use the term merch did you not okay
so all right we're dealing with commerce
markets we're interfacing directly with
the public and they're buying power
um there we are you uh should if you are
interested in having us address your
questions
know that you can file super chat
questions during this first hour
that we will answer during our second
hour
that's right um so anyway thank you for
doing that if you have questions about
any of this you can email
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
and the person who answers that email
will
likely respond to you unless you're rude
in which case they may not
yes yes indeed i'm using the they simply
to preserve
their pronouns because they don't go by
they no they don't
no all right so we want to talk about um
big game hunting in pre-columbian
america uh whether or not
you when you say something with anger or
with love or with any kind of emotion it
changes whether or not the thing itself
is true
uh let's see we want to um
ask what the game theory behind uh
bailout funds for
uh for riders
in portland might be and how that's
playing out and then
um finally and perhaps for you know a
lot of the time here today we're going
to
wonder and then investigate whether or
not asking questions like that
make us all right you feel all right
today not all right man
the question is far right well but
they're both they're both listed there
yes both listed all right okay um
so it's big game hunting let's let's do
this i'm excited for this yeah
yeah you're excited you you're excited
for me to go out big game hunting and
dragoma moose uh no i'm excited to
discuss whether or not it would make
sense for you to go out big game hunting
being a woman and all
a woman at all yes i'm not just a woman
i'm a woman at all women and all
right yep um frying up that moose in a
pan
yup it's good though it's good though
all right um okay uh here we go
zach let's just show show my screen here
this was published
in uh science i think
it wasn't one of the science uh
secondary publication so i don't know
does science do that is that just nature
that does that
i'm uh i'm confused by science advances
at the top is that advances in science
or is sciences advance is a thing but
exactly
no it's science advances actually it is
one of the sort of knockoff
knockoff science magazines this was
published in uh
november november 4th of of last month
so
um just a month ago called female
hunters of the early americas
and um i want to just actually rather
than the abstract i think in this case
the introduction
um provides a slightly better
introduction
rather than the abstract which is a
summary of the whole paper so just the
first
paragraph of the introduction reads as
follows big game hunting is an
overwhelmingly male biased behavior
among recent hunter-gatherer societies
such observations would seem to suggest
that this gendered behavioral pattern is
an ancestral one
ostensibly stemming from life history
traits related to pregnancy and child
care
which constrained female subsistence
opportunities however
a number of scholars have theorized that
such division of labor would have been
less pronounced
altogether absent or structurally
different among our early
hunter-gatherer ancestors
and here instantly they have like eight
nine
uh references early substance economies
that emphasized big game would have
encouraged participation from all able
individuals
aloe parenting which appears to have
deep evolutionary roots in the human
species would have freed women of child
care demands allowing them to hunt
communal hunting which also appears to
have deep evolutionary roots
would have encouraged contributions from
females males and children whether in
driving or dispatching large animals
moreover the primary hunting technology
of the time the atlatl or spear thrower
would have encouraged broad
participation in big game hunting
pooling labor and sharing meat are
necessary to mitigate risks associated
with the atlatl's low accuracy and long
reloading times
furthermore peak proficiency and atlatl
use can be achieved at a young age
potentially before females reach
reproductive age
obviating a sex bias technological
constraint that would later intensify
with bow and arrow technology
last the residentially mobile lifestyle
entailed by big game specialization is
quite conducive to human reproduction
and thus female hunting
contrary to previous thinking because it
reduces net movement relative to central
place foraging strategies
this hypothesis is consistent with high
population growth rates among early
hunter-gatherer populations
so i wanted to read that in part because
i wanted to be able to say atlatl a
number of times
yes which i have i will have more
opportunity to say as we proceed but um
so you have not actually spent any time
with this paper no i've spent a little
time oh you have okay so
i have a number of things i want to say
but do you have any immediate response
it's not your first response but yeah
sure um so first of all a number of
things
one um there is uh as i'm sure you will
get to
a very broad pattern uh in populations
where you have both hunting and
gathering there
is this overwhelming uh bias towards
males doing
hunting or at least big game hunting big
game hunting long distance multi-day
hunting right um and you know that's not
really
in question here that's they don't
question it right
well nor should they the evidence is so
overwhelming that this is the general
pattern that it just simply is and the
question is recent hunter gathers right
is what they is what they say right the
evidence is for recent is
is clear they say recent
hunter-gatherers which really just means
uh the extant and those recently enough
extant um for us to have good evidence
and so what we have here
is sub-fossil evidence sub-fossil
meaning it has not been converted to
stone
these are buried remains in the new
world which is
independently interesting that the new
world may have had different dynamics
uh unfolding that suggests a
female hunter of big game
now the place where the rubber meets the
road here as far as i'm concerned
is the nature of the evidence and how
justified we are in actually inferring
what they have inferred here yeah
um from it so um i think that
introduction did not explain the nature
of the evidence
at all uh yeah the nature of the
evidence is burial sites
right that they have um they've found
20s they've got 27 burial sites
i think if memory serves it's all in the
andes yeah this is
this is um
tropical america at elevation which most
people wouldn't call tropical although
technically it's tropical but it's at
elevation so it's not hot and humid
it's sort of got a temperate climate
while being actually
really tropical so andean habitats
with 27 burial sites in which a full
hunting toolkit
was buried alongside people um
and in these 27 burial sites there are
16 that are men
and 11 that are women which is
statistically
a not um apparently not a decipherable
difference so it looks like you know men
and women are equally likely
to be buried with a full hunting toolkit
which in
other places has been interpreted as
evidence that you know you're buried
with
the stuff that you used in life yeah
that is that is the that is the
that is the one big inference here now
not so
fast there dr hying okay okay so
among the things that are worth paying
attention to here here's a thing that if
you
study um paleontology you will
have to grapple with which is the
ability to distinguish
a male skeleton from a female skeleton
is
not nearly the straightforward thing
that that one would imagine it that the
morphological distinctions that we see
in a flesh and blood human are actually
not so reliably reflected in skeletal
uh structure that one can simply look at
a skeleton and say one way or the other
now if you have
they are looking at not just
osteological they say but proteomic and
isotopic analyses
i know they do but the question is what
are these kinds of evidence and
how good are they right so a the
skeleton doesn't tell the story in and
of itself
if you have so let me just let me pause
here so i did not spend a lot of time
considering their evidence i
i i spent a lot more time thinking about
what it would mean um
if it were true and therefore how likely
it is that that um
that it is true um but super fascinating
that you would be arguing that you can't
tell based on um the
even just like just the shape and size
the you know
robust versus gracile nature of male
versus female skeletons at the same
moment in time
what sex they are because i mean this is
a position that that i at least and i
think
you um have been very clear on with
regard to you know this these this is
one of the things that
on average is highly highly different
between
male and female but of course those
population distributions
males and females at a particular moment
in time are also highly overlapping
right and that's the problem is that
they're overlapping so you know
if you looked at a large population of
skeletons and in some sense they have a
small population of skeletons here
which you cannot assume
are equally so if you had karyotype
evidence yeah you know what i'm
so i'm i'm not i'm not buying this
because because pelvis pelvis width
alone is highly highly core
it's highly predictive of sex right but
first of all there's a reason that
hey i don't think their fossil evidence
is so awesome here in terms of
quality of these skeletons
archaeological evidence they're they're
right there well sub-fossil anyway but
yes they're archaeological evidence
because i believe now you spent more
time with this paper than i did i
i breezed through it it looked to me
like they were inferring this
from for example the gracile nature of
a femur i think it was
and so i don't think they have complete
skeletons here
i think they have fragmentary evidence
and that
the reason that they are using three
different kinds of evidence here one of
which is actually new to me and i don't
i do proteomic no no the proteomic i get
right so proteomic is going to be
basically protein evidence right i just
so
20 years ago it wouldn't have been
called proteomic
doesn't make any difference i don't know
it's let's put it this way they are
inferring sex from
a certain amount of skeletal evidence
and then a bunch of
molecular evidence now why the molecular
evidence would be substantially
different between males and females i
don't know
why the morphological structures would
be different is
clear but let's say for example then i
don't think there's a population on
earth for which this would be true
yeah but let's say for example that this
population
buried only its men right maybe it
does something else with its women
they've not been discovered or the
whatever the burial procedure was
resulted in the complete destruction
of those skeletons so you had a
population that was all male
and then you come at it with the
assumption that half of these are
something like half of them are likely
to be female
and you start figuring out which ones
are the females so your assumption
causes you to impose
femaleness on a population that doesn't
have any right again i'm not saying that
that's
likely but i'm saying we don't know
we're inferring
a number of things one we are already
if they have it correct that some of
these skeletons are female
and that they are buried with what they
call a full kit for big game hunting
then we are inferring that the
implication of that is that these people
use those kits in life
and therefore in the afterlife would
have some need of these kits
which makes perfect sense i'm not
arguing it doesn't make sense it's
the first level inference would be yeah
they buried them with a kit of things
that they would be likely to need in the
afterlife and the afterlife is similar
enough to life
that one can infer their in-life
behavior from this
but that's not a dead certain chain of
argument
for sure there's there's um there's
uncertainty at each step
i will say that apparently and this
again i this is not where i spent a lot
of time thinking about this paper but
their citation for why they used all
three of these methods for sex
estimation in combination is based on an
also very new paper
called a comparison of proteomic genomic
and osteological methods
actually that's one genomic versus
isotopic i think an isological methods
of archaeological sex estimation
um which i have not reviewed uh but
anyway they're
they're they were using multiple methods
in order not to get
so apparently the osteological stuff can
be spurious but very rarely when
combined
right so all i'm saying so let me just
say
i believe that they probably have this
right and that it probably does make the
very interesting implication that they
derive from it my point is just
that um we are caught in this bind where
we're looking at a
very tiny sample from one place
that very tiny sample we are imposing
a viewpoint on who is of what sex based
on
three kinds of evidence none of which
are secure in and of themselves but
together
they make it much more likely that it's
right assuming that whatever we've used
to calibrate these methods
matches this population right and the
population could be distinct in some way
and then on top of that assuming that
we've got
the sex of the skeletons right and
uh that therefore we know who's who we
are
inferring things about a belief system
from
physical evidence that cannot possibly
report the belief literally all it can
do is imply why else would you bury a
person
with a hunting kit if they weren't going
to need it in the afterlife and why
would you need it in the afterlife if
you didn't need it in life that's
so there are a lot of steps here where
something could be weird and there could
be something
wonderful in what's weird and we might
never find it we might never know
but the point is at some level
the most parsimonious interpretation of
the fossil
or sub-fossil evidence that they've
found is that women
were engaged in this population in big
game hunting in
uh high andy and south america
uh yeah i think actually that that
is right predictions of whether or not
you can generalize that
to um to habitats outside of the
particular one that they were in or to
other moments
uh would be uh i i think they're they're
real limitations that i would predict
only in certain habitats and i'm not
sure like one big question for me is
what game were they hunting
this is the americas remember this is
you know this this is this is south
america
i'm not i don't i don't know what they
were hunting and it's going how they
were hunting is going to depend not just
on their tools
which primarily it turns out we're at a
laterals um but also on what it was they
were hunting
so but hold on um it's going to depend
on
what tools they were using you know if
if if it's a
bunch of men with hand axes if it's a
bunch of people with hand axes it's
not likely to include women um for
reasons that we'll get to
and um although cooperative hunting is
what we're
imagining here it's really unlikely that
um
that women are going to have been
hunting alone right like that that men
going out hunting alone
even in populations where cooperative
hunting is the rule uh which certainly i
imagine have happened sometimes at least
for some types of game
um but the prediction would be women are
not likely to have
to have done this alone um we're also
engaging in inference here um but
well i mean there's a number of places
to go i want one place i do want to go
here is um we've got this
national geographic article about this
research which has
uh you know of course an illustration
that i think is quite misleading here's
a woman a
and a skirt b um hunting alone
and she is i don't think she's in a
skirt
well something a tunic of some sort um
but she's but she's hunting alone and i
guess you know it is it's kamelot's that
she's hunting which is the only thing i
came up with for what they would have
been
hunting we've got spectacled is also a
possibility
yep um oh my god okay um
so but not
not there actually so i don't it depends
on what the actual habitat was like at
the time because spectacle baird was
would not have been above tree line
right spectacle bear uh are are in
sort of cloud and just above level of
like montane forest
in the andes but not above tree line not
in the sort of habitat that she is
she is illustrated in in there
um and we have a quote in that article
um
which is pay wall so i'm going to just
read it to you rather than
try to show it to you a quote from an
archaeologist who was not involved in
the research kathleen sterling who says
um did the newfound toolkit belong to
the buried individual
sterling challenged the inquiry itself
we typically don't ask this question
when we find these tool kits with men
she says
it's only when it challenges our ideas
about gender that we ask these questions
now that strikes me as an attempt to
shut down
investigation you know she she appears
to be
questioning a you know until very
recently
clearly male dominated way of
understanding the world that was present
in archaeology
but just because that is true does not
mean that we shouldn't always question
the inferences that we're making
in what we find now so i thought um to
sort of counter
that um you know apparently feminist
critique
of anyone who would question whether or
not these were in fact women who were
hunting big game
i wanted to read a tiny bit from this
amazing book one of my favorites i can't
i don't know where the camera is
mother nature maternal instincts and how
they shape the human species by
the uh extraordinary evolutionary
biologist sarah blaffer hurdy
and i guess sort of an academic sibling
of ours she is an academic sibling
heritage she's a student of bob trivers
yeah exactly and we are students of bob
trovers yeah
so she wrote in this 2000 book which i
highly recommend
no doubt patriarchal bias played a role
in victorian and earlier ideas about
motherhood
and yes such pious biases permeate the
writings of evolutionists from the 19th
century onward
it was an all-male club and unwittingly
darwinians accepted the biased
assumptions handed them on a platter by
their predecessors who were more nearly
moralists
than scientists the same biases were
still very much in evidence in 1975 for
instance when e.o wilson published his
pioneering work on sociobiology which
included a notoriously inaccurate
description of foraging societies that
claimed that quote
during the day the women and children
remain in the residential area while the
men forage for game or its symbolic
equivalent in the form of barter and
money
a victorian in a 1950 suburban ideal of
mother tending the hearth was
substituted for the actual life of a
highly mobile pleisocene gatherer
but wilson let's recall was an
entomologist and how to give himself a
crash course in ethnography in order to
write the chapter on humans for
sociobiology
perhaps more telling professional
anthropologists themselves failed to
register this whopper
even anthropologists who had actually
helped collect the data indicating that
a woman in a hunter-gatherer society
might travel a full 1500 miles in a year
while carrying a year old baby the error
was simply overlooked because it
corresponded with expectations about
how the world should appear so we had
we had a literature we had fields that
were utterly involved in
sort of moralistic unscientific
naturalistic fallacies
type of thinking um in which they've in
it was
even like backwards naturalistic fallacy
right they were they had an image of
what they thought
should be true and they backfit even
when um
even when the data suggested entirely
opposite things that's confirmation bias
yeah and you know women um have have
were never sedentary and agriculture
largely changed that that
that was the moment um that that did
transform
um sex roles uh rather dramatically
into being more and more divided in
terms of the labor that we were doing
but so you know that history is part of
what uh archaeologist sterling and other
people are pushing against
but it comes across as deeply
anti-scientific and of course will get
in the way of progress and of actually
getting
you know getting to understand what
these data truly mean
so um female hunter gatherers never
sedentary
obviously that's just that's that's not
that's not the job
um but were they big game hunters
across lots of habitats on the regular
or so low
probably not right because well upper
body strength
is remarkably lower in women than
than men on the other hand the atlatl
is pretty light uh and um
and i i got to spend some time on
worldadolatl.com
today i'm thinking about aladdin's um
describes the action of throwing one
which i have never been lucky enough to
do
as akin to that for throwing a ball or a
stone and so you know you don't
you can't throw like a girl um from you
know from the elbow you have to throw
from the shoulder but
you know anyone who actually is engaging
in the physical world and throwing
things is throwing from the shoulder
and um you know depending on its weight
uh it's
a woman could be expected to throw it
quite effectively
in looking for what the weights of these
things were which i never did quite fine
but they seem to be pretty light
i came across a 2013 blog post from a
female researcher at the royal
saskatchewan museum
describing her experience learning to
throw out a ladles while at an
archaeology field school
and so this is just an anecdote but i
found it interesting
quote one of the grad students in the
archaeology department had made the
atlatl and had also manufactured
one of his darts from a graphite rod
that he had purchased in no time i was
throwing that dart 100 meters with ease
and some of the other young men in the
group were throwing the darts 300 meters
the darts disappeared out of sight when
they threw them
she doesn't make a comment about this
she just she just
says it um so let me just this is um
evelyn siegfried um who is at the royal
saskatchewan
museum who reports just this anecdote
without any explanation in part
because guess what it's obvious of
course men are going to throw things
farther than women are
and we you know we see we see this in
all in all throwing sports
um less so though interestingly
in things like walking and even
endurance running
the disparity between men and women at
you know at top performance
is a tiny fraction in walking and
endurance running
uh as it is in things like throwing
because our the disparity
the average disparity in upper body
strength for men and women
is um gosh i can't remember but
something like 30 to 70 percent i'm not
sure about those numbers whereas the
average disparity between top um
top endurance runners for instance uh
men and women is
closer to 10 that's interesting and you
know and why
well until we became um
people who had homes while we were still
roaming
everyone had to keep up yeah right
everyone had to keep up and for a period
not only do women have to keep up but
they kept up
while carrying their babies and in fact
in many extant hunter-gatherer
populations
women actually carry more load on
average than men do
so women had to keep up with men and
they tended to do so while carrying
more load and so you know they shouldn't
surprise us that actually endurance in
terms of locomotion is not that
different
but that doesn't mean that we're not
different in other ways and
like upper body strength which we are
absolutely all right so i wanted to go
down a little other
road here great um so i looked uh
carefully at the date
that they believe these sub fossil finds
are from
they said about 9 000 years ago
so that's right that is i believe
going to be well after
the megaphone extinction that happened
uh coincident with the end of the last
ice age
i think that is true although i did not
i have not lined those up for sure
the reason that it's relevant is that a
what they
were hunting might arguably have been a
larger list
if it was before that extinction had
completed
but also i've you know there is a debate
and i think the debate is actually
headed in the wrong direction or at
least it was the last time we checked in
with it
about why the megafauna of the new world
went extinct about the time people
showed up
and it seems clear to some of us that
the best most parsimonious answer
is that the megafauna of the new world
having never been exposed to people
before
behaved rather like the fauna in the
galapagos currently does and what
darwin noted so clearly about it which
is that it just doesn't run away
right it doesn't have experience enough
to know that a human being is a
dangerous
creature and um therefore it is very
easy
for human beings to over hunt and that
basically
when your dinner is friendly right right
when you you know
when your creatures just look at you
curiously and you can
uh can overwhelm them and so anyway one
of the questions i had here was
if i don't think that there's going to
be a general and persistent pattern that
yes in fact
women have been doing a lot more of the
big game hunting than we expect i think
there's some tendency to evolve
towards a division of labor on this but
that exceptions are likely to have
happened this probably isn't the only
one
sure and it may be about something right
like for example
it may be that as the continents of the
americas are
not yet full with people and i think
they there's a strong argument to be
made that they never were full that they
were still in the process those
populations were growing at the point
uh that europeans showed up even if
there were 100 million people here
before columbus
right and the estimates are 50 to 100
million people and the question is what
what
would those numbers ultimately have
become and
what implication does it have that
carrying capacity for these two
continents
if you can use the concept in that way
had not been reached and therefore
selection would be very different right
it's not zero sum selection it's
quite different which i think would
account for many distinctions and one of
them
might be that
in effect one does not need to be at
peak
hunting performance of the kind that
would make
males the much better resource for the
job
because it may be that the hunting
pressure on
these environments was somewhat less now
you have to be really careful with an
analysis like that shows
even if the continents were not at
carrying capacity it doesn't mean that
your local habitat wasn't and obviously
you hunt local to your habitat so that's
really where the rubber meets the road
but
um but there's some question i guess as
to
at the point that human beings arrive in
the americas from
uh from beringia what world did they
face
and what kind of hunting did therefore
reward and then what was the
evolutionary trajectory in other words
the prediction of this hypothesis would
be the farther back you go from that 9
000 years ago date the more female
hunting you would see
right and the closer you come towards
modernity the less you would see
right so i don't know if we'll see that
pattern or not but i love the prediction
it's a valid prediction
yeah that's that's great and it's um you
know
if we trust this method of assessing
whether or not there were female hunters
which you know with asterisk asterisk
asterisk we've made all these caveats
um but you you could test that
prediction simply by continuing to keep
track of
um you know what the sex of those who
are buried with full hunting kits
yeah exactly that would be yeah if an
ability to age them and you're our agent
our dating
techniques are are pretty good they are
if well calibrated they're pretty darn
good
um yeah i'm more doubtful about the sex
assessment sure
on any individual find right if you
really have a population
then you can tell on the basis that you
really do have different averages but
yeah so the problem here in part that
you're you are concerned about with
regard to sex assessment is
uh with only whatever it was 27
individuals
um you and you know only in
not none of them together you don't
actually know
what the representation for the
population is you actually you don't
have any idea
right you have no idea and nothing with
which to calibrate it
um yeah so that's uh
that's that now i i do have one other
place i hesitate to go here because i
think the scientific discussion here is
so good on its own and frankly
you know as much as there are places
where i will raise skepticism about
whether or not they got their sex
assessment right and whether or not the
toolkits imply what we generally take
such toolkits to imply
i do think you know if i had to guess i
bet you they found what they think they
found and it's pretty interesting
right but
that analysis if we put that just
slightly to the side and we say now
we've got the problem of this analysis
is now happening
in the present now you and i have argued
that
there is a renegotiation of the deal
between the sexes
that is long overdue and that there are
many things which may once have been
divided by sex as a matter of division
of labor that have no reason to be in
the present
and the realities of mating and dating
have changed too as a result of birth
control and many other
factors and so we it is the moment that
we effectively
have to renegotiate we can't go back
because the old stuff doesn't make sense
in the modern world
and a free-for-all doesn't work either
so renegotiating the deal
is is where uh where the smart money is
however we are now in a context in which
these um narratives
you know a scientific narrative about
women having done or not
done big game hunting in the past are
going to be contentious by virtue
of their implication or the implication
that people will wrongly take for the
present
you know they will they will fall afoul
of the naturalistic fallacy
and they will want to read things into
this but so you you go two ways here one
you've got the likelihood that um
women were hunting big game that uh
to the extent that evidence for that
might have existed in past
samples that it might have been missed
by academics who were
very likely to be male and very likely
even if they weren't male to view things
through the eyes of
ancestral academics who you know
could make foolish errors like eo
wilson's uh
imagining that women were you know back
in camp you know keeping things tidy
uh so anyway uh
there is a very real reason to worry
that bias has been
playing some role in these in our
ability to understand these stories or
find them or look for them or whatever
it would be
and so great that we have evidence that
really does strongly suggest
if through a series of assumptions that
are all
um somewhat iffy but does seem to
suggest that there was some sort of a
different deal in the americas at least
high in the andes at least 9 000 years
ago
there was some different deal between
the sexes that's cool it's a model for
the fact that
actually these things can be
renegotiated right so i think that's all
positive
on the other hand we are now stuck
with the possibility um
how do we know let's say that these um
skeletons that were buried with these
big game hunting toolkits
uh were assigned mail at birth and then
were
transparent okay
if we take really well that's where
we're going
okay here's my point if they were
assigned female at birth trans
and went hunting then the answer is that
in fact
they were men there's no news here
right
it it does point out the lunacy and
frankly the misogyny of much of the
modern trans ideology
right so what i really the point i'm
really trying to make
um i mean hey we're bypassing a
tremendously good joke about
the authors of this paper having dead
named these fossils but
or misgendered them or whatever they did
but um
but the real point here is i guess you
could dead name someone who was already
dead
yeah double deadness that's worse
because why you know you're kicking them
when they're down
all right that's also a terrible joke
but
here's here's my real point my real
point is
on the one hand we have the awesome
messy fascinating story of human sex and
gender in one population that most of us
you and i spent a fair amount of time
thinking about the high andis but most
people don't yeah right
this marvelous story that just the hint
that these
fossils have of some different deal
between the sexes
that existed right compare that to the
mind-numbing story
that you know that actually there is no
sexual binary in the whole scientific
attempt to impose that on people is
wrongheaded to begin with and they
were whoever they felt like they were
when they were hunting and there's
nothing else to be seen here
that's a nonsense garbage story and
anyone who believed that 9000 years ago
left no descendants right exactly if you
were that confused as a hunter-gatherer
you weren't a very good hunter-gatherer
right so anyway the point i guess is
look can we get over this stuff
can we just embrace the cool messy
interesting sometimes awful story that
is reality and
stop trying to impose morality on it and
you know
purify it and police those who would
dare think other thoughts
yeah right that's good all right you and
me will start with that agreement
i think i think we should um just one
more thing that occurred to me
uh that i had not made the connection
before with this paper if this is nine
thousand years ago in the andes we
actually read a site
um chobshi uh that is thought to have
been
active about eight thousand years ago so
you know
that's both a long time a thousand years
between those but um but perhaps
the habitats were the same enough and
the culture was the same enough
uh in which people took cover in this
really shallow cave
and apparently hunted by funneling
guinea pigs and rabbits and porcupines
off a cliff
and retrieving the corpses or perhaps
having to kill the corpse
the the not yet corpses at the bottom
who were injured
um and then they turned those things
into food and clothing
and so if we add that as another
possible method
which we know like shobhi is a well
documented and pretty well studied
archaeological site
um you know there would be there would
be little reason not to have
all members of the group who were living
at this cave go down with their atlatls
and dispatch
uh any animals that they wanted to eat
who were injured at the bottom actually
i
i love this and you know whether or not
that story is
right or stands in for some other story
it makes the point that actually you've
got one population here
which gives us one set of archaeological
finds that suggest one
unusual feature that we didn't expect
but who knows what the idiosyncrasies of
the hunting environment were at that
place and as sho she shows
you can have all kinds of things you can
have one particular cliff that you know
animals don't see coming and if you can
scare them in that direction they
you know do most of the work for you and
so you know could this be responsive to
an idiosyncrasy of the landscape was it
idiosyncrasy and time you know creatures
that
were more plentiful and less likely to
run away who knows but
really at some level that's the
fascinating thing is what were the sum
total of inputs
that caused selection to spit out this
output if in fact this output is what we
think what caused that
and it wasn't going to be one thing it
was going to be a combination
of factors that's right all right good
uh i mean we could keep going on but uh
maybe that's that's that for now
so you wanted to talk about um
oh yes about our next topic yes
you want to introduce this do you want
zach to show the screen or not um
sure why don't you show the the screen
so
what we have here is kareem carr who is
a phd
student at harvard who made a big splash
several months ago on the topic of what
on earth two plus two might possibly
equal and his point was
all of you who think it's four are
failing to grasp just how subjective and
arbitrary
mathematics is and so
in any case the world descended into
madness over this
for some time now 2 plus 2 equals five
is also
uh an oblique reference to orwell 1984.
this is
um i don't know is it newspeak or
it's some sort of it's it's one of the
modes by which you
force a population to totalitarianism if
you can get people to agree
that two plus two equals five well
you're well on your way
right and just um the the kerfuffle from
many months back
was lead on the side of no two plus two
actually does equal four um by our
friend jim lindsey
yes um so anyway most people will
remember that if they are on twitter at
least they will have
seen some part of that battle and kareem
has
decided to um blow on the embers of that
battle
to see if he can rekindle it and i what
has he said so we can just
yeah i'll just get this off he's got two
tweets here he says
when someone says two plus two equals
four in a really angry way they're
admitting that the statement
can't what the statement can't do for
itself one can't calmly state it like a
fact it is
it supposedly is one must back it up
with a threat of force to make it stick
and this
act affirms the spirit of two plus two
equals five he goes on
and he says so even when they think
they've won the argument
they're losing their defensiveness and
anger is already
a loss because it brings two plus two
equals four into the subjective
where it belongs so
those two last points being angry brings
the statement into the subjective
and the subject the subjective is where
it belongs yeah
now so the reason to be here is not just
simply to harp on the absurdity of what
kareem khar
is saying and to try to parse it and
finally get it right so people can
finally understand why two plus two
equals four
because as i said to him the first time
through this what he is engaged in
is a classic example of sophistry which
is to say
his argument is hard to field which
doesn't say anything about its being
right
and his argument if you go back to his
original claim had to do with the fact
that the symbols
two and five and equals and plus
are all something that we simply agree
on and there's no reason to agree that
they equal this or that
and so they could equal other things and
therefore the statement two plus two
equals 5 could be a totally reasonable
statement as good as 2 plus 2 equals 4.
and the answer is
that's not just sophistry i mean that's
but colloquially people
mean when they say semantics and it's
not actually something
it's not just sophistry but he's not a
phd
student just anywhere it's harvard level
sophistry yeah right
so anyway that is what it is that's not
really the point
to return here the reason i wanted to
return is that it struck me when i saw
his new argument
that this was actually an interesting
opportunity so
uh several years back i think 2017 i
gave
a talk in vancouver
that i called how the magic trick is
done and how the magic
was done was basically a sort of a
taxonomy of tricks
and kafka traps and uh other
things that are causing um
the social justice ideology to actually
wield a great deal of power in spite of
the fact
that the arguments that it's making are
um
not correct in many regards and
what one does not typically see so one
of the things i said in that talk
is that these techniques evolve
people try a lot of stuff and the stuff
that doesn't work doesn't
leave a fossil right the stuff that
works
gets picked up on and it gets augmented
and it gets built into a very refined
strategic
structure that we realize needs to be
talked about at the point that it comes
for us and we can't field it because
even though
we may be right about something it is
very difficult to figure out how you
deal
with the incentive surrounding so this
kareem khar
next chapter here struck me as the rare
case where you might be present for the
birth of a new technique
right if you think about his argument
here
if people say two plus two equals four
and they get
angry about it then their anger is an
indication that two plus two does not
inherently equal four
right well this is an amazing argument
right this is stunning because what this
says
is first of all two plus two equals four
is a baseline nearly foundational level
of societal agreement right we have to
agree with these
symbols mean if we're going to establish
truth at all we've got to establish what
the meaning of words is what the meaning
of symbols is
what the operations that they dictate
are and when somebody
asserts that 2 plus 2 equals
4 is not inherently true
they are attacking something fundamental
i mean you
you know if you imagine if we were to
invalidate two plus two equals four so
two plus two
suddenly equals question mark
modern world ceases to function
instantly
right there's no device that we're using
that doesn't depend on that level of
agreement and a great many things
stacked on top of it
it's like um many years ago our younger
son
toby asked me what would it be like here
if there was no gravity
and it's it's exactly that there there
wouldn't be there's no here
right no nothing nothing that we know
has happened
in that world and the same is true for
two plus two equals
what now right exactly so in some sense
what carr is saying is we have the right
to attack the very foundations of
systematic thought and we have a right
to do so in a politically charged
environment where
those of us who are doing that are
actually dictating policy
not only are we saying two plus two
equals five but defund the police
is you know a reasonable thing to demand
so it is natural that somebody who
thinks oh my god
how did two plus two equals five get out
of orwell and into the world
and you know why is it marching right
that
could make a person very nervous they
might be right to be nervous
and they might speak with a certain
amount of urgency and saying no 2 plus 2
equals 4 god damn it
right and the point is that has nothing
to do with whether or not 2 plus 2
does or does not equal 4 that just has
to do with the fact that what is in
jeopardy if it doesn't equal four
is really important so but it's but it's
as you say
a slick rhetorical move that probably
just dies here but maybe not
so i mean this is it's like it's like a
reformulation of ben shapiro's famous
facts don't care about your feelings
this new formulation is feelings about
facts change the facts
yes feeling feelings about facts are
all you need to figure out whether those
facts are in fact factual right
um so and then the final point i would
make is
i i want people to understand just how
beautiful and diabolical his formulation
is right so let's
say that let's give him the benefit of
the doubt here and let's say
okay for the uh for the
uh purposes of this argument his uh
assumption is to be taken literally if a
person responds angrily to the idea that
two plus two equals five then they imply
that two plus two does not equal what
they think it equals okay
now let's apply that across the
population okay
what if all of us but
one decides you know what
i'm going to say this very calmly 2 plus
2 equals 4.
my hand does not shake i am not raising
my voice 2
plus 2 simply equals 4 and that needs to
remain true
right but one person isn't so good at
keeping their
they're calm yeah right they're cool and
they get angry because they're worried
right well that one person has now
invalidated
two plus two equals four and left us in
a world where two plus two
now equals i'm your new king and you
will bow before me
that guy's anger blew up the universe
blew up the universe and so
in any case what i'm hoping is that our
discussing this
here on darkhorse will result in um
this particular uh attempt to generate a
new super weapon
failing because people will realize just
how crazy it is
um but nonetheless maybe the point is
it's actually
sophisticated enough as a strategy that
in spite of this analysis it will
continue to grow and be augmented and
wielded and we will see it
morph into all sorts of things out in
the world we don't know yet
well i mean in part in part it may well
work in part what we're doing here
may not touch the effectiveness of the
strategy precisely because we are trying
to do analysis
and if the strategy works it will work
exactly on the emotional level
right it will it will affect how people
view things
um because they will have been informed
by the emotional content of people who
are certain that actually if you claim
two plus two equals four well then
you're probably a fascist or some such
yeah uh absolutely so it could be both
we could do the analysis and it actually
might have
an influence in a particular quadrant
but have no impact on
uh the utility of this argument it could
still be an evolutionarily stable
strategy even if it's dead wrong
yes it didn't raise your voice you said
dead wrong in a strong way but the
amplitude was
perfectly a little a little sarcastic
maybe yeah yeah
but that suggests strength i think
actually oh it works
in reverse okay we're good then all
right
um uh third item
of of four um
people's generosity in um across the
country with regard to
people in portland us seems to be being
used to help out criminals
pray tell what might you be talking pray
tell um
let's see uh the before we show before
we show
the screen uh funds that were created to
pay bail
for people who were arrested while
engaging in vandalism or assault or
whatnot during the protest and
especially during the riots in portland
have been wait for it abused by those
receiving the pale money
who would have thunk color me [ __ ]
shots
color are you [ __ ] shocked all right
yeah so here
just let's show the the tweet before you
start talking about it
from defense fund pdx some folks think
that bail funds can sustain themselves
because most bail eventually gets
refunded
in portland bail paid is returned to the
person arrested not the person that paid
the bail
we have paid over a hundred thousand
dollars in bail since may
we've only had a few folks return their
bill to us if you've had your bail
refunded please consider sending it back
to us if we paid it
you can return it via any of the methods
found in the link in our profile
if you want to mail a check dm for our
mailing address
gee shocked people who are arrested
for criminal behavior and get their bail
paid for them
from the generosity of well-meaning
liberals i would think mostly
um but there's no expectation tied to it
at the point that they actually
show up for what would it be their
arraignment um is it that is that when
you get your bail back
at whatever point in the process you
show up and you get your bail back they
get their bail back
it's not theirs but they take it and
they keep it
because of course they do yeah so i
should tell you
at one point during the portion of
these riots that was attacking the
uh the courthouse downtown yeah um
i went down there spiking around and i
saw
two people who were part of this bail
fund standing next to a sign about
donating to it and utilizing it and all
of this and i was shocked because
hey the whole idea of a bail fund
uh certainly intervenes in the
incentive structures surrounding these
riots in a way
that immediately it was obvious like oh
what you're doing is you're dropping the
cost of rioting if you're arrested
during
a riot i mean a the state abuses
these um penalties so one of the things
let's leave rioting out of it for a
moment if you are
protesting peacefully you can be
arrested
for all kinds of violations trespassing
protesting without a permit all sorts of
stuff yes and
it's a nightmare for people that it
happens to and
you know basically we had friends up in
olympia to whom this happened oh yeah
and there's a whole set of undeclared
penalties that come in the form of
bureaucracy that surrounds
you getting your due process right so
it's an actual actual nightmare and in
fact the cops
when they're going to arrest people at a
protest will often give them a choice
right they will say do you want to be
arrested and the basic point is if you
don't want to be arrested then you have
to do what we say and if you do want to
be arrested
then don't do what we say and we're
about to arrest you and then those
penalties will kick in and so anyway
it's a sort of
unspoken uh rule under normal protesting
but
in this case you've got people who are
rioting
you've got other people who are
signaling their virtue the riots are
ostensibly about challenging
racial inequity right they're not but
they say they are
you've got people who want to advertise
that they are in favor of racial equity
who are signaling this by donating to
this
fund to bail out these people who are
really in you know
in this portrayal uh uh misbehaving
you know civil disobedience right
um and by the latter day throws by
lowering the penalty here you are
increasing the
uh incentive to continue right now if
this if these were really peaceful
protests and they were really about
injustice that would be one thing but in
the context where
they are um actually attacking
courthouses and trying to pick a fight
with the cops and demonizing people and
threatening to kill them and all of
those things
it's preposterous to lower those costs
but what it turns out is that it's even
worse than i thought by a lot
because what's really happening is that
those who are donating
to reduce the cost of being arrested
are in effect paying people to engage
in those behaviors that get you arrested
so
what you have is people behaving in a
destructive and violent way
whose bail is then being paid they are
freed
and uh when they get the money back
it comes to them so it is a payment
scheme
for those who are behaving in in these
in these ways
and and what a perfect tell for whether
or not these people
actually uh believe in the values that
they espouse
most of most of these uh these people
will tell you that there's something
akin to socialists
yep um or you know or farther farther
left than that
right and um the the honorable the
important the valuable part of socialism
is returning that which belongs to the
community to the community
right is if you have a fund that is a
pool that is designed to help people
like you and you have been helped in the
past you keep that pool alive
by returning it to the pool when you are
done
this is you know this this is human
decency 101 but it's certainly
important um if you espouse any kind of
collectivist
uh thinking and anyone's failure to pay
back that
reveals them as exactly the opposite
yeah individualistic
um
yeah it's bad faith um and at some level
this is
subsidized anarchism and when you ask
yourself why it is that portland
has ongoing uh destruction of property
and violence
you know uh then this is part of your
answer is that
when you apply these principles locally
in this ham-fisted way
what you do is you end up paying people
to riot which is an absurd thing to pay
people for
right it's uh it's the most absurd
jobs program conceivable
yes okay so um you feeling pretty far
right
uh not as much as some people would have
you imagine
yeah yeah yeah neither am i um never
have
um we now we now have a number of of
conservative
friends yeah i wouldn't say any far
right nope no
no one far right by usual standards but
um so
hold on my computer is taking me a long
time to pull this up
this uh is in a pre-print server
as of what this week last week uh this
week
okay um so for those of you listening
not watching
um yeah so that's last week i guess yeah
um
well that's when you downloaded it or is
that oh i think
that's when it posted yeah okay so for
those listening not watching this is uh
always
oh boy i'm gonna butcher her name
hussein marty
perhaps at all a six authored
um yeah six authored
a pre-print that is to be published in a
peer-reviewed journal
presumably um published just two weeks
ago a week and a half ago called
evaluating the scale growth and origins
of right-wing echo chambers on youtube
and uh just zach may i have my screen
back for a minute
um just to jump to uh
one of the main conclusions here uh
this paper makes the claim that the
channel you are watching now if you are
watching this youtube channel brett
weinstein's youtube channel
along with sam harris benjamin boyce
mike nena
gad sad rebel wisdom many others are far
right
and that's on a that's on a five point
scale we got far left left center
right and far right fox news is right
we're far right we're far right
fox news is right and we're far right
yeah um
and you have let me see if i can
pull this up uh
sorry this is going to take me a minute
here we go
um this is page 26 of the article the
text of the article is actually very
short but there's
um many many pages of appendices and and
references and such
here we have label aggregation how did
they decide whether or not you were far
right
right center left or far left well they
relied heavily
on a few references and
here is this this bullet point here at
the far right
any oops any channel labeled as alt
light
artrite alt-right idw
or mra men's rights activists by
reference
20. or conspiracy idw alt-right mri
outline religious conservative
by reference 23 or right or conspiracy
are all right
um so let's just talk very briefly about
a couple of these references
20 um reference 20 which is a big part
of where they are hey zach can i
um thank you um
a big part of where they are basing
their
assessment uh is a reference that
doesn't even exist online
uh you have it's ribero at all 2020
and when you search here on google
scholar
um it looks like it undid some of my
search but
uh you find
oh that's super interesting between my
search a couple of hours ago and right
now it is now showing up
um so that's that is
new and it's taking a while um okay so
this is
um the basis by which they this
this paper is the basis by which uh the
paper we're talking about is deciding
whether or not um
channels are um are far right and here
this is the first time i've seen it
because i literally
was not up a couple of hours ago we
analyzed 330
925 videos posted on 349 channels which
we broadly classified into four types
media the alt light the intellectual
dark web and the alt-right
and what they say is
or what the hois and marty at all paper
says
is that they that that reference that we
just
were looking at was based largely on the
data data and society
paper um from uh from what a year or two
ago which your brother
eric weinstein roundly um roundly
criticized uh with some
with some clarity i would say he
debunked it
yeah it's it's total garbage right um so
you know that
the and frankly the the the take home
with regard to this part of what we want
to talk about
is if you have been identified as a
member of the idw
or are claiming to be in the idw
intellectual darp web this
this term that your brother that eric
weinstein invented
um then you are all right end of story
all right sorry far right end of story
that's that's that's it
um and that that is the claim
made in this paper that simply if you're
idw you're far right
and um and please stop bothering us now
but
that that can't even be true can it
because
um if that was in fact the sole basis of
the categorization then obviously eric
himself
would be far right and he's categorized
as center so
there must be more to their
categorization scheme uh than
is a parent were you
headed somewhere no yes but go on well i
was just going to say
uh what's more reference 23
is it would you go there yep
the other primary uh reference that they
relied on in this paper
so uh when challenged in this paper and
i challenged uh
the authors of this paper on twitter and
one of the authors david rothschild
uh responded extensively his point was
look
we borrowed our categorization from
these other
references and uh we did the analysis
well and we were plain about the fact
that we had done that
but in fact that's not the case and uh
mark ledwich contacted me pointed me to
a thread of his
in which he showed that the analysis
which this uh huss and marty paper
claims to be utilizing
uh in fact doesn't match their own
categorization and i looked at
uh lead witch's um paper
and in fact it categorizes us as
center so there's something very
interesting going on here where
in effect the hassan marty paper simply
asserts that idw
is far right right it hard codes that
into their analysis
and this i think has every danger of
being used as a pretext
for barring channels from uh
from youtube in particular and you know
this paper was about
um youtube so
where are we headed you're talking going
um so i wanted to
point out a number of things one what
would it mean for this channel
to so uh the lead witch paper
um categorizes our channel
as anti-sjw but center
and actually this matches i think what
the content of this channel
uh repeatedly does and we can go through
some of the things people will have
heard us
talk about let me interrupt here a
moment i did not spend a lot of time
uh with the um
what is it the lead witch and uh zaitsev
paper yep
um but the paper on which they based
much of their um
no the the hoisin money paper
is only actually looking at data from
2016 to 2019
so you know we'll we'll get here i think
but
fascinating to me that you know i just
went back and looked at that point we
hadn't begun our live streams at all
so i think there's a couple of videos
that i show up in in
in earlier but your channel had 40 but
your channel had 43 videos up at that
point
here they are uh it includes such
far right questions as why do plants
make medicine
sympathy and empathy and evolutionary
perspective marriage is an evolutionary
phenomenon
in here somewhere what do bowerbirds
want um
and and and so on and you know the only
you know we've got uh a somewhat
conservative voice here in douglas
murray
and a conservative voice in andy no um
here you are criticizing um stephen
crowder
um you know chloe's no chloe valerie is
no
conservative john wood is but again
conservative
and far right are not the same thing and
certainly katie herzog isn't and mike
nina isn't and sam harris isn't it
yeah it's a wide diversity it's what you
would expect from a centrist yeah a
centrist channel but i guess asking what
bowerbirds want is now far
right i guess so yeah um so i wanted to
i don't know what order to do this in
but first of all there's some question
and there was some consternation online
about whether or not
the analysis was claiming the channel
was far right or the audience was far
right now it's very clear from the paper
that what it's saying is that the
channel is far right
and not the audience and we can talk
about what it would mean if the audience
was far right which it also isn't but
um zach could you i think it just is
agnostic about the
audience i don't think it's not
suggesting that the audience isn't
it's in fact it in in some ways actually
because it concludes that
actually this isn't due to youtube
suggestions it is due
to inherent choices of people watching
youtube so it is
kind of you know closer to making the
argument
that the the viewership also is
of the political ideology that they're
assigning us to whatever right
um then other arguments other analyses
which are just saying actually it's the
youtube algorithms that are that are
that are radicalizing people right so
they took their contribution
to be um they took whose contribution
who told the huss and marty paper
sees its contribution as another
mechanism
that is not the result of the suggestion
algorithm radicalizing people
yes so but here's the point okay is the
channel far right
zach could you put up the uh political
compass test
that's my political compass test i've
taken it several times
now i take uh no pride in the fact that
my dot
is hanging there off almost the farthest
left edge it can be hanging off it's
there for reasons
um that i think are quite clear what i
would say
is as i've said many times i believe
we have to engage in radical change or
we will perish
i think radical change is frightening we
should be very very cautious about it
but i don't think we have a choice about
it
that said people have also heard me say
that markets are by far the best
mechanism we have for figuring out how
to do things
right so why is my dot so far down in
the libertarian end
is because i believe that actually
meritocracy
is the best mechanism and markets are
the best mechanism
but why am i on the far left edge
because i believe
we are far from a meritocracy in which
everybody has access
and um that markets have this uh
frightening dual role where they're very
good at figuring out how to do things
and they're absolutely
terrible at figuring out what we should
do and so
anyway it explains that dot can i just
clarify possibly one thing that you said
which is that in the past you have
clarified that you
would love to live in a world in which
you could be a conservative
right um you have
no interest in trying to live in a world
without markets because you
like i understand that markets will
always exist
and that trying to uh that we need well
regulated markets
that an utterly free and unregulated
market um is a recipe for disaster
but that trying to obliterate markets uh
will also end in disaster
yeah and i also you're not trying you're
not seeking a world without markets
um right right now i want to mark i want
a world in which markets are free to do
what they do very very well
and um and you're right i don't want to
be
a progressive i want to live in a world
where we're doing so well that progress
would be a mistake
and i know we don't live there yeah so
you showed you showed your political
compass test but maybe even though
the information um in this paper which
makes this channel
far right uh basically doesn't include
me at all but it's possible that i'm
dragging you down maybe i'm maybe i'm
you're maybe
i'm the right way i have wondered about
that yeah yeah yeah so here's
my political compass test oh my god um i
am
farther right than you are right of me
yep and uh
still and still okay so so here here's i
think the
there are several points that we need to
make one is
if your goddamn method looked at this
channel
and decided we're far right your method
sucks right you can just tell that this
diagnoses your method and your method
is garbage okay so what i would say is
we are not the only channel that got
caught up in this
lots of channels that are clearly
nothing like far right
and i would say although you and i are i
would argue far
left our channel is center because the
point is
we are analyzing uh perspectives from
all over the map and you know basically
it's heterodoxy
and well we're also specifically
challenging the errors on the left
more than we are actively challenging
the errors on the right because it's our
own home
like this is the place where we live and
the right should clean up their messes
should prioritize in cleaning up their
messes and the left should prioritize
cleaning up their messes and we should
all be able to come together and convene
and you know we do take some some [ __ ]
from people
uh for not cred you know for instance
for not criticizing trump enough
and you know what a it's been done
um to the degree that we have had any
you know unique perspectives on
what's wrong with trump i think we've
said it but it's been it's been rare
because he is so
you know so fully analyzed i was going
to say well analyzed i don't think it's
been particularly well done
um but but the fact is that when you see
the thing that you
are come to have some sort of a pathogen
in it
of course you're focused there as
opposed to the more distant enemy um
yes i think that's uh that's quite
right um but i also
do want to take a brief step down the
road of well
you know what about this maybe has to do
with audience and
point out that even if it were true our
audience is not far right we know this
we know that there's a good deal of
right of center stuff but i would say it
is center to the extent that there is a
bias in the audience it might be
center-right
but let's say that there were far-right
people listening right
to rate that as a radicalization problem
if you have two people with political
compass tests that look like ours
and people from the far right are
listening to us isn't that a success
isn't that good that people who maybe
you know are too
extreme to be reached in general are
actually hearing somebody from the far
other end of the spectrum
and that that might be de-radicalizing
them and you know to the extent that you
just want to put together a giant list
and i must say this is the moment of
putting together giant lists
right to the extent that you want to
compile a giant list of people and you
want to say that gad sad
and sam harris and brett weinstein and
benjamin boyce and shuon head and all of
these people
mike nina right if you want to just
shove us all into a corner where we
not only don't have to be listened to
but you can
safely um dismiss us
as contributing to the problem then
you're actually contributing to the
problem right you're
you're making this um a worse phenomenon
so
uh the fact that the method doesn't work
that it is predicated on at least one
paper in which the authors of that paper
are alarmed at the abuse
of their work in which
the authors of that paper on which this
current paper is predicated
reached a different conclusion in other
words ranked us
as center rather than far right that
suggests that
whatever they're doing they're not even
doing it um well or consistently or
accurately
that's right and then this raises a
question which is
why why are they doing this right
now i was shocked when i saw this paper
you have something you want to add just
maybe before you go into why
can we show anna zaitsev whose name i am
probably mispronouncing
who was the one of the co-authors on one
of the papers
that was supposedly used to build these
categories and who objected strongly to
those categories
posted a long excellent piece on medium
which for some reason isn't coming up
right now but we'll put it in the
description of the video the final
paragraph
of which is as a researcher my greatest
goal is to find the truth about youtube
algorithms radicalization and political
bubbles
i am confident that our prior study and
websites recfluence.net
and transparency.tube offer currently
the most thorough
accurate nuanced and technically the
most advanced representation of the
political spheres on the platform
so i just thought we should show these
two um
very very briefly this is rec it's rec
fluence rec fluence.net i've plugged in
your name
um the tags you know it's it's not a
complete listing of tags at all of
course
um but of these tags on the left here
and i'm not going to read them all i
apologize for those
uh of you just listening not watching um
but the
tag um that your channel that this
channel get spread is anti-sjw
not really just conservative obviously
but not conspiracy not partisan right
um you know certainly you know not even
not anti-theist
um none of those uh and you know if we
if we plug in
just you know well let's see what will
your brother come up as i don't know why
this isn't working there we go
um same right and you know his
connectivity is slightly different here
and if you scroll down you see you know
like like for you connections to you
know sam harris
and the reuben report and powerful jre
and then the other site that um
that the co-author of the paper
uh mentions is this one
transparency.tube
where you can just plug in any channel
and find out
what tags and this is just a slightly
different set of tags
this channel seems to come up with and
in this one you're anti-woke
and center yeah and that's that sounds
right
for for this channel right and so the
options here
are mainstream news partisan left
partisan right
anti-woke social justice late night talk
show
state-funded conspiracy religious
conservative politician libertarian
anti-theist socialist manosphere
q anon and white white identitarian
which interestingly and not surprising
at all to me
um is is a tiny number of sites
um with a tiny number of views compared
to all the rest of them and yet that's
that's the big bugaboo that's what
everyone is actually scared of
well that gets back to why yes okay
good so this question whether that's
what people are scared of and people of
course have a right to be scared
of white identitarianism um but there's
a question about how great a danger
it poses whether that danger is worse in
the context of a woke revolution that is
basically defining people by skin color
in a way
that is liable to create that menace
which i have argued on this channel
but so
there's several there's several points i
wanted to make one i consider
the fact that lefties
have a channel that is center to be
something of a triumph because what
we're striving for
here is to be objective
and the reason i think we come out as
center is because
um basically you have political teams
evolving and if you are committed to
figuring out what the accurate
perspective is
on a wide diversity of topics what you
get is something that doesn't match any
team's slate of beliefs
right you get a la carte uh analysis
and and given the options partisan left
and partisan right
we explicitly have always but um also on
this channel
aim not to be partisan right we you know
we we believe what we believe
and we are seeking to understand reality
but partisanship should not be part of
that
right which is i think the the hazard
here is that you know you could say the
very same thing
about joe rogan for example right
joe rogan himself is a liberal quite
clearly
right he has people from across the
political spectrum
and he treats them honorably and i think
something has understood him to be a
great danger
not because he's either on the far right
or because he appeals to the far right
but because if you are trying to control
the narrative and wield power on its
basis
heterodoxy is dangerous and so how do
you get people to punish heterodoxy
you portray it as something dangerous in
and of itself in other words
if you take the people who are
navigating the center
who are heterodox who aren't putting up
with [ __ ] and you can portray them
as somehow in league with a bunch of
white identitarians
then you can explain why you're purging
them from platforms and this may sound
hyperbolic except you know
articles of unity was suspended from
twitter remain suspended
i was kicked off facebook without
explanation and then brought back
with an obviously phony story
jordan hall has been kicked off facebook
as far as i know he has not been
restored to it so you know we've got
this thing on the march which is
actually deciding who has access to the
world through
these platforms and who doesn't and
there is
every reason to fear whether it is the
explanatory in the case of this paper or
not
there's every reason to fear that those
who have something to lose in a proper
heterodox analysis of the world
conspiring to get rid of voices that
they cannot
beat on a level playing field and that
is my concern here is
whether or not this set of authors and
we need to get back to who these authors
are and
why that matters but whether or not
these authors
were motivated by whatever it is that
caused data in society to release that
terrible report in other words if
there's some behind the scenes thing
that wants to create reports that will
justify purging people from platforms
or whether they are simply responding to
the fact that there is demand for papers
like this
right and therefore they are basically
you know evolving into a niche where
they haven't been part of any such
discussion doesn't really matter because
the role that's going to be played by a
paper like this
is to justify action and you know what
happened in this paper
well you had heterodox voices
simply hard-coded grouped in with
unsavory voices in a way that then
appears to be the conclusion of the
paper
right it was built in as an assumption
and it appears to be the conclusion and
the conclusion
if all you do and you know it occurred
to me
that a paper like this functions rather
like an end user license agreement
the number of people who are actually
going to read this paper is tiny
the number who will understand it is
even smaller than that and so the real
point is well what was their conclusion
oh we've got this far right thing and it
comes from something other than
recommendation algorithms what can we do
about it yeah well there's no reason we
have to give these people platforms is
there
yeah um go ahead uh before you get back
to you said you want to talk about
the authors but um as i was reading it
this morning this paper um which somehow
i had remained
ignorant of until last night when you
mentioned it for the first time
um i was thinking about how it is that
we do animal behavior
and i use i as you know i use to teach
students how to do animal behavior um
quite a lot with a with a strong
focus on epistemology on how it is that
we make claims of truth
uh and on the entire part of the
research process
not just the statistics not just the
experimental design not just the
hypothesis generation not just the
communication of
uh everything at the end but the entire
thing from
from pattern recognition and you know
initial observation
of of what it is that you think might be
true to hypothesis generation a full
slate of hypotheses etc
um that you that could possibly explain
the phenomenon
and i was imagining um a student new to
this
you know an 18 year old perhaps who
decided that they wanted to study
territorial behavior in ducks which was
a fairly
uh common thing that students would do
because ducks are common enough and
and territorial enough that you could
actually you could actually see this
happen whereas in a 10-week
project it's hard to see animals do much
if you actually go out and try to find
it
but say you now the one of the first
things you need to do is figure out what
what it is that you're calling
territorial behavior right and
one of the one of the things that people
who haven't done animal behavior don't
realize
is that if you go in with an idea of
what territorial behavior
is and anytime you see something that
reminds you of territorial behavior you
call it territorial behavior
you have simply fed your assumptions
into your work and when your work spits
out your assumptions back at you when
you look surprised
um you're fooling yourself in the world
that's not science it's terrible right
it's it is it is absolutely not science
but it's a
it's how a lot of this is done actually
a lot of published work
operates that way you plug in your
assumptions into your model whatever it
is even if you're not using some kind of
a fancy statistical model
and you get those assumptions fed right
back out at you
and guess what you're really not
supposed to be surprised at the point
that that happened so
if you went out and started looking at
ducks and you see
um some males actually up in the water
on each other and you know bumping
breasts and
and um and engaging with each other you
would have to very carefully code what
actually you were seeing
but there's a good chance that that
actually is some kind of an altercation
either over a potential mate
or a territory um you still had don't
know that for sure but
um let's let's put that in the probably
you can take data on that sort of thing
with clarity enough um and and
make an argument that is territorial
behavior but maybe you're also because
you know what a territory is and it's
about defending a a perimeter
um you're observing some some ducks
uh swimming along what you've what
you've identified as a perimeter and
occasionally coming up against a
another male duck and um and and then
engaging in one of these you know breast
to breast altercations you know okay
well
sometimes um patrolling the perimeter is
also territorial behavior
good and then you say well maybe
whenever
they're anywhere near that line at all
it's territorial behavior
well maybe whenever they swim in the way
that they do when they're near that line
it's territorial behavior
maybe whenever they're kind of anywhere
near an area that i've seen them at
other moments engage in territorial
behavior it's territorial behavior
you see how your expansion of categories
can can grow
and it will make your data collection
easier because now you have more and
more examples of territorial behavior
the problem being
it's not really territorial behavior
what you've collected is a whole bunch
of observations of things a tiny sliver
of which may in fact be territorial
behavior
but most of which is not and then no
matter how good the rest of your work is
no matter how good your experimental
design is or your observational design
which is a total legitimate way to test
hypotheses and allot behavior no matter
how good your statistics are
your analysis your description your
literature view all of this no matter
how good
all the rest of it is it's not science
the research is crap because the
categories
that you put your observations into
were simply wrong and that i think is
exactly what's going on here
yes and in fact um i have heard
and see in this paper that there is some
properly done work quite a bit of it in
this paper
properly done on a garbage data set and
so
no i don't i don't even think the data
set is garbage right
i think the labels on individual things
the labels the categories the bins
right but if you just if you stripped
the labels and re-labeled
what what we saw by um
uh boy what was his name mark ledwich um
says
actually i think a lot of this work was
well done but they took
my and zaitsev's data and
strangely categorized i don't know what
they did well
you and i are going to get into a thing
over this because i and you know
the same thing would go for mark ledwich
which is
a when i'm saying that the data set is
garbage i mean
with the labels right i'm not saying
that you couldn't analyze these
channels independent of those labels and
get a reasonable analysis but
the but the point is there is no such
category
as um this is good work
but for the fact that what you fed into
it spit out a conclusion that you
started with
okay let me just so the fact that the
math the fact that the quantitative work
is well done
i think speaks to the fact that the
nature of this paper
is in fact pseudo-quantification and it
has
strong confirmation bias it suffers from
overfitting and that it is
in fact ironic that it suffers from
overfitting because three of the authors
of this paper have written another paper
on overfitting so they're in fact so
well
versed in overfitting that they
completely understand
what it is and yet have fallen into this
trap and so my feeling is
i don't know why it happened but a paper
in which
you apply a mathematical method
correctly to a data set on which it is
not justified
is a bad paper okay i don't i'm actually
not convinced that they've over fit
their data
i'm not convinced that they've engaged
in pseudo-quantification
and i think our disagreement is about
this category
of garbage data set um there there are
multiple ways for a data set to be
garbage
on which you should not then do analysis
and
um in my mind the the sort of
platonic ideal of garbage data set for
which that term should probably be
reserved
is a data set that is fraudulent at some
level
in which the data themselves have been
have been either made up or specifically
biased in
this case you have um
a kind of fraud in terms of the
categories the labels
but you could fix the data set
by changing the labels and everything
else about it we are told and this is
not
our wheelhouse i can't assess the the
mathematical analysis here right i just
i don't have the skills
um but we are told by someone who does
yeah i think actually the analysis was
good but the categories are so
bad that you cannot trust the results
that's a different kind of garbage data
set than one in which the data
themselves aren't good
i don't care that it's a different kind
of garbage data set it's a garbage data
set
and the fact is the net effect is
overfitting confirmation bias and
the i mean it's like saying if your lab
did 20 experiments
of the same kind and got one
statistically significant result and you
published that one
that you would say oh well that paper
was good now that paper wasn't good
if you knew that you had that well it's
a lot like that because what you
what you have is a competent
use of techniques on things that these
authors of all people
should understand are not justified you
you cannot apply these techniques to
that data set
encode it in this way and get anything
out that isn't the conclusion that you
started with
but it's just the encoded in this way
part that is as far as i can tell
the problem i don't think that anything
else
um in it is is wrong here and and i
think
you may be objecting because it sounds
like i'm saying it's just this one
little thing
this one little thing is foundational
and without this one little thing being
correct it renders the entire
interpretation and the rest of the paper
null and void frankly and it shouldn't
have gotten through peer review
right it hasn't but okay um because
because it really
it it really is a kind of scientific
malpractice
but there are a lot of other steps at
which they could have done bad work and
they didn't and that is
not a justification for the bad
categorization
and bad categorization is not a trivial
thing at all i don't accept this
these people these are not uh
unsophisticated people take care look at
that author list
all right uh hold on here we go okay
uh you have you can show this first of
all you have um
these are top flight institutions
pen harvard santa fe
institute microsoft research
um and you have this prior paper on
overfitting so they're aware of the
hazard
you have top flight people at highly at
important institutions
wielding techniques that they either do
understand and wielded badly or don't
understand and should have and the fact
that they did some of the work right
constitutes no part of a defense of
what they released especially in light
of the fact that what they released
actually stigmatized people with
channels and put them in a situation
with respect
to platforms that decide whether or not
we have access to the world
there's there's no um
if you took let's say that you did a
drug safety trial
and you knew that the mice were broken
in such a way that they would lead you
to believe that the
um the compound in question was safe
even if it wasn't
right and then you say well we did the
drug safety trial perfectly
the only mistake we made was we used
mice with long telomeres
and the answer is well okay but why did
you do that did you know that they had
long telomeres or did you not know and
if you didn't know
shouldn't you have known right now there
are cases in which somebody might know
might not know in the mouse situation
but in this case they have everything
they need not only
did they have
did they have the knowledge as to what
the assumptions of the test that they
were going to apply
required but they also had the fact that
prior work had categorized these
channels differently
so what's their excuse and then i think
frankly the most conspicuous thing here
it seems like an anomaly but why did
they categorize erica's center
right now eric has a hypothesis about
this which i think belongs on the table
okay his hypothesis is that because eric
has engaged in
challenging conservatives on their
channels that he reads differently
which suggests that they did a fine
level of encoding here that they looked
at his channel and it looked different
because of uh something he has done
i think this is very unlikely for one
thing i've done some challenging of
conservatives on
conservative channels too and so it's
possible that those are read differently
that eric has been more forceful about
it or
it was done somewhere that it showed up
in their data set well it's it's
supposedly the analysis is entirely on
the home channel it's not about the
person who grows the channel so it
really it
that according to what they have stated
about how they categorize channels
that should have zero bearing um but
well for either of you right for anyone
and in fact given what they do show
about how they categorize the simple
fact that eric
not only is the idw but he named idw so
how
it is that idw justifies being put in
the far right column and eric ends up in
the center
but anyway my point would be what i
think actually
is likely to have caused eric to be put
where he was put
is that he was so forceful in debunking
the data and society report and so in
some sense
the cost of putting eric in the far
right category
was probably regarded as too high which
suggests
if that is the mechanism here what it
suggests is that this isn't even
data right right that this is um
cherry picked in order to reach a
conclusion and for what purpose we can
only speculate
but if if the answer is that idw was
misunderstood to be far right
then eric wouldn't be in the center
category the fact that he is in the
center category suggests that this was
massaged for some purpose that we can't
this is true and
um you know i see
those institutions ought to be concerned
that they have people putting
uh work this bad into the world and
the fact that it's people who have the
relevant expertise and therefore this
isn't just some sort of
mistake this is um this is the
equivalent of academic
malpractice that ought to concern them
yep no
i i agree with that um i
i am not compelled um by your argument
that there's
overfitting or pseudo-quantification and
such but
uh the category errors are profound and
fundamental and render the entire
analysis
um not worthy of considering as to
whether or not it might not be
it might be true or not because there is
effectively
it's built on not even a house of cards
it's built on nothing
how is that not pseudo-quantification
well what i mean i guess i need a
definition then of pseudo-quantification
because i'm
you know in terms of the actual uh
analysis that they did
um presumably and again you know not not
my wheelhouse and i cannot assess
um but other people who can assess who
objected to what they did categorically
like in terms of categorization
said um the way that they performed the
analyses aside from the categorization
they did it well
well but they did a mathematical
analysis on
a data set that is subjective and purely
so
so that is pseudo-quantification they
have taken something that isn't
quantitative in nature they have made it
pure quantitative and they have spit out
a result that suggests that this is the
written yeah i mean it suit a
quantification
yeah i can i can see that argument um
and
you know there's a there's a long and
rich history of
turning things that aren't numbers into
number like things and uh
and uh then doing things to them that
you can only do to numbers
right in you know also in the natural
and physical sciences but especially in
the social sciences
and i guess i hadn't thought of that as
pseudo-quantification exactly but
perhaps it is exactly that i think it is
exactly that and you know overfitting we
can
argue because overfitting is
traditionally a purely statistical claim
but the point is they've got a model and
they basically
shoved the data so that it fit it and
you know
exactly what you would expect has to be
true which is that things end up in
categories that no reasonable person
would put them in
in order that the model spits out this
answer so
yeah it does it does seem conclusion
driven
and you know that's that's
editorializing on my part
um but there is it it almost reads like
glee with regard to the conclusion
that the far right um like yours truly
are ascending in the world and oh my
goodness we must clutch our pearls and
try to figure out what to do about it
well and in fact when a bunch of us
challenged this david rothschild one of
the uh authors
on the paper responded on twitter that
he was getting a lot of big
feelings from you know idw circles when
in fact what he was getting was
critique yeah um so anyway yeah there is
a lot of uh oh
the last thing i want to say about this
is that
um something else that uh david
rothschild said on twitter
suggested that um it's rothschild oh
okay uh in any case that he was
um getting a lot of pushback and that
they were open
to changing the categorization
of channels now on the one hand i have a
feeling our category is going to get
changed right
what i'm concerned about is that as
happened with facebook the only people
who are going to be able to get
out of this out of the way of this
juggernaut
are people who have a sufficiently large
channel
to embarrass people who write terrible
papers like this
into uh taking them out of the line of
fire and
you know that cannot be yes
right the fact is you either do the work
properly as uh as i think
these other authors have led which
insights have led which insights they've
done right that this is a model for how
you do this work
carefully or you don't do
it at all and to the extent that your
work is going to be
used to shape policy inside of youtube
or wherever
you have an absolute obligation not to
stigmatize people
and it we can't live in a world where
you get to stigmatize the people that
you want to stigmatize
and then those people who have a big
enough channel can get some sort of an
indulgence because they can make us
think about it
cut it out right you've demonized a lot
of people as far right you've raised
you know this particular white
identitarian uh
specter over people who have
no interest in such things and in fact
they're exactly on the other side
of the spectrum and um shame on you for
doing it
so cut it out and you know that applies
to everybody big channel or little
doesn't make any difference
yeah now that's good shame on you stop
it
all right well i think we are i think
we're ready to give our little
end end piece and take a 50-minute break
and then come back to answer your
questions
in the next hour so we'll be answering
your super chat questions
from this hour and from the next hour
starting in
15 minutes or so um you can
once again find um dark horse
shirts and and hoodies and bags and such
at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
[Music]
um email the
moderatordarkhorse.moderator gmail.com
um if there are items that you don't see
that you'd like we're
working on some other stuff some of it
is harder than you might imagine
um a few things that we've considered
are
perhaps epic tabby and people wolf
merchandise yeah possibly if we can make
that happen totally possibly some flint
knapped
tips for your atlatl oh yes and we have
them
in putnam house by fairfax
i'm going to regret having said that
aren't they yes especially because
the colors that we use to
associate with the different sexes is
definitely highly labile
and has changed from arc lead in fact
even as recently as victorian times
were exactly the opposite yes we have
them in blue and black
i don't know we have them in gray at a
different grade right
yes um flint knapped heads for your
spears that you're using with your
eyeladles perfect um we're going to have
to get our um
our moderator right on that yes she's
going gonna start flint knapping um okay
uh darker's membership at my patreon um
has a private q a every month we had
um ours last sunday it was you know two
hours uh
intimate enough that we can actually um
look looking on the chat it's
very nice it's it's fun um
you have patreon conversations a couple
times a month
with patreons at a higher level you had
one this morning
i didn't know and you have your second
one tomorrow morning yep
so people can uh join your patreon um to
see if they
go to your patreon to see if they want
to join that i have not sent out the
uh invite for tomorrow's because i
thought some people might sign up for it
today
and i want to make sure they get the
invite but anyway i will send that out
let's say by five o'clock
pacific time tonight all right
you get access to a discord server at
either of our patreons and of course you
have a clips channel
uh that's got a lot of clips uploaded
with with a fair bit of frequency
that's it it's december
it is december we will see you in 15
minutes we'll see you in 15 minutes
and then again for those of you
listening we'll um we'll be back in a
week
all right be well everyone